[Musique]
chèrs aulnésien charbon dit noah cher
peut visionner en 2017 vous m'accordez
votre confiance en m'élisant députés
durant les cinq années de mon mandat
j'ai eu à coeur de vous représenter à
l'assemblée nationale j'ai mesuré chaque
jour la responsabilité qui était la
mienne portez votre voix à aulnay sous
bois a bondi aux pavillons-sous-bois
j'ai souhaité entendre vos difficultés
partagez votre quotidien et défendre vos
intérêts avec pour seul objectif
améliorer la vie de chacun d'entre vous
je suis candidat et souhaite me
présenter à nouveau devant vous pour les
élections législatives des 12 et 19 juin
prochains je veux continuer à mener les
combats nécessaires pour protéger les
habitants de la seine-saint-denis
comme je l ai toujours été je resterai
un député de terrain prêt à soutenir les
projets de notre territoire que j'aime
tant dans lequel j'ai grandi et où je
vis et pour lequel je suis engagée
depuis de nombreuses années ma fidélité
ma proximité ma loyauté ont toujours
guidé mon action aux côtés de nos mères
bruno beschizza katia copie stephen
hervé avec qui je travaille pour les
habitants de nos trois villes en cette
période difficile où les difficultés
s'enchaînent et s'accumulent et façon
nombreux défis que nous devons relever
je suis et je serai toujours à vos côtés
[Musique]